is it hard for you to say that like  there will be a day that you maybe  aren't a warrior no quite frankly the  writings on the wall I understand the  business we tend to get into this  mindset of someone owes us something  because of what we've accomplished  you're gonna be an idiot to walk around  feeling that way like I feel like you're  just setting yourself up for failure  you're setting yourself up for  heartbreak you're setting yourself up  for disappointment as opposed to saying  no let me learn this business if you  don't get to know the business then you  can be blindsided and be like oh man  well everything I've done there I  thought I'd be there forever I would  love to be I understand the luxury tax I  understand you got these young guys and  contracts up and they have to get paid  like I understand all of those things  and so just for me that's what I mean by  the writers on the wall